i
[Música]
estas son las noticias de francia 24
máxima expectativa en eeuu en dónde
avanza el conteo de los votos en
condados y estados clave para determinar
quién será el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden conquistó winsconsin y
es el virtual ganador en el estado de
michigan mientras que donald trump
lidera el conteo que aún continúa en
pensilvania y georgia
inconforme con los resultados parciales
el presidente y candidato republicano
donald trump pidió un recuento de los
votos en el estado de wisconsin al
tiempo que indicó que presentó una
demanda para impedir que siga el conteo
de votos en michigan y que sean
recibidos más votos en pensilvania
trump ha afirmado sin tener ninguna
evidencia que hubo fraude mientras que
bardem ha reiterado que deben ser
contados todos los votos
y también en el senado los partidos
republicanos y demócratas están en un
virtual empate que les otorga 47 escaños
a cada uno mientras que la cámara de
representantes allí lidera el partido
demócrata
[Música]
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora vamos a comenzar en eeuu en donde a
esta hora sigue avanzando el conteo de
los votos en algunos condados y también
en algunos estados todo esto para
determinar quién será el nuevo
presidente de eeuu aún se mantiene en
suspenso los resultados en los estados
de alaska nevada georgia carolina del
norte y pennsylvania hace pocos minutos
fueron dados a conocer los resultados de
michigan hasta el momento el candidato
demócrata joe biden lidera el número de
votos electorales con 264 mientras que
el presidente y también aspirante a la
reelección de ahora el trompo por el
partido republicano tiene 214 votos del
colegio electoral esto mientras continúa
como lo decíamos el conteo de votos en
condados que son cruciales
y en la madrugada de este miércoles y
sin presentar ningún tipo de evidencia
alguna el presidente y también candidato
por el partido republicano donald trump
afirmó que hubo fraude en estos comicios
presidenciales al tiempo que se declaró
ganador de esta contienda estas fueron
sus palabras esto es un fraude para el
pueblo es una desgracia para el país
estábamos listos para ganar esta
elección francamente ganamos esta
elección
[Aplausos]
entonces nuestro objetivo ahora es
asegurar la integridad por el bien de
esta nación es un gran momento este es
un gran fraude fraude mayor para esta
nación y queremos que se utilice la ley
de manera apropiada entonces iremos a la
corte suprema y por su parte desde la
ciudad de wilmington en el estado de
delaware el candidato demócrata joe
biden reiteró su llamado a la prudencia
y su confianza en el sistema electoral
estadounidense mientras avanza el conteo
de votos y también se mostró confiado en
que de continuar la tendencia que se
está presentando podría llegar
rápidamente a los 270 votos electorales
que necesitaría para llegar a la casa
blanca también hizo un llamado a la
unión del país estas fueron sus palabras
es claro que estamos ganando en
suficientes estados 270 votos electores
para ganar a la presidencia yo estoy
aquí para declarar que ganamos estoy
aquí para reportar cuando la cuenta esté
finalizada que creemos que seremos los
ganadores buscan con todos los votos con
todos
hemos ganado wisconsin por 200 por 20
mil votos virtualmente el mismo margen
que el presidente trompo obtuvo en ese
estado hace cuatro años y para conocer
más detalles de lo que está sucediendo
allí en eeuu vamos a conectar con diana
castañeda en la ciudad de washington dc
en la capital muy buenas noches diana
allí en la capital tantos seguidores de
joe biden como te donald trump se han
dado cita en el centro de la ciudad
ambas partes se muestran optimistas de
acuerdo a este escenario que se está
presentando con este conteo
de los condados clave en diferentes
partes del país
así es nosotros nos encontramos al lado
de la casa blanca es muy difícil verla
debido a las barreras que han colocado
de rejas y también de concreto para
proteger alrededor del servicio secreto
lo ha hecho pero desde la noche de ayer
seguidores más en su mayoría de joe
bayrén porque aquí en washington 10 y el
90% de la población está registrada como
demócrata han seguido minuto a minuto
los resultados de estas elecciones tan
ajustadas en varias plazas en varias
parques también se han instalado
pantallas grandes en donde la gente y
seguidores de bailén han seguido estas
resultados y también hay muy pocos
seguidores de trump si hemos visto
algunos han asegurado cuando
conversábamos con ellos que están
respaldando lo que dice el presidente de
que se ha robado digamos se ha hecho un
robo frente a estas elecciones y se
espera que también hemos comenzado a ver
cómo llega cada vez más gente a darse
cita acá frente a la casa blanca de
manera espontánea a la espera de que se
conozca quién será el próximo presidente
de los eeuu también pues la seguridad
está reforzada en todo el centro de la
ciudad
hoy no abrieron comercios y tampoco
oficinas diana muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de washington dc
y la capital de eeuu también donald
trump y yo videncia lista para una
eventual batalla legal la campaña del
presidente de donald trump pidió un
recuento de los votos en el estado de
winsconsin donde el candidato demócrata
fue declarado ganador por otra parte el
mandatario y también candidato
republicano donald trump presentó una
demanda para impedir que siguiera el
conteo de los votos en el estado de
michigan que hace unos minutos otorgó ya
estos 16 votos al candidato joe biden y
espera una respuesta también por parte
de la corte suprema para que el estado
de pensilvania no reciba más votos
inicio en las urnas pero la batalla por
la casa blanca entre joe biden y donald
trump podría terminar en los tribunales
el conteo de los votos sigue aumentando
la ventaja del candidato demócrata
hayden ganó en wisconsin por un estrecho
margen pero la campaña del mandatario
pidió un recuento de los votos
argumentando irregularidades en varios
condados
al equipo de camps también anunció una
demanda para evitar que continuará el
conteo de papeletas en michigan donde va
a ir en lidera dice que no tuvieron
acceso como observadores y exigen
revisar los votos
eso se acabó vamos a apegar nos vamos a
ganar la elección y de hecho ya le hemos
ganado es cuestión de contar los votos
con justicia la batalla también se
centra en pensilvania que tiene hasta el
viernes para contar las boletas enviadas
con fecha del 3 de noviembre así lo
determinó el tribunal superior del
estado pero los republicanos apelaron la
decisión en la corte suprema que tiene
la última palabra
donald trump aseguró que el máximo
tribunal resolvería el resultado de la
contienda el presidente instaló allí
tres jueces y reforzó una mayoría de
seis magistrados conservadores frente a
tres liberales los demócratas temen que
los jueces puedan apoyar los planes del
líder republicano y definitivamente el
estado de pensilvania se ha convertido
en el centro de la tormenta política en
la puja por el voto electoral entre los
dos candidatos el maría ángulo de la
redacción de france 24 nos explica la
importancia de este estado para estos
comicios
pensilvania otorga 20 votos electorales
lo que equivale a la mayor cantidad que
aún queda por definir
así las cosas y throne gana en este
estado aseguraría la reelección en medio
de la incertidumbre los habitantes se
muestran divididos pero confiados en que
la decisión final no genere hechos
violentos en su territorio
no creo que aquí haya violencia en todo
eeuu creo que podría haberla y ya sabes
hemos tenido muchos disturbios y esas
cosas y creo que podríamos ver eso pero
no por aquí no lo creo
los ancianos
es el día después de las elecciones y
ahora tenemos que esperar 4 días para
saber quién ganó eso es absolutamente
absurdo va a hacer lo que necesite para
llenar sus propios bolsillos y los
bolsillos de la gente que está moviendo
los hilos dice muchas cosas para la
gente pero honestamente que ha hecho en
los últimos cuatro años nada
de acuerdo con lo indicado por el
gobernador de este estado demócrata tom
wolfe todavía restan por ser contados
más de un millón de votos por correo por
lo que los señalamientos de trump sobre
el presunto fraude serían solo parte de
un ataque partidista con 12 millones 700
mil habitantes pensilvania es el sexto
estado más poblado del país uno en el
que a diferencia de otros como georgia
los votos por correo no fueron
procesados con antelación por lo que
trump afirma que las papeletas contadas
desde el cierre de las urnas serían
fraudulentas
saludamos a antonella martí ella es
analista política y directora del center
for latin america en la ciudad de
washington muy buenas noches antonella
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y comienzo por preguntarle su opinión
sobre estos pedidos estos reclamos que
está haciendo el presidente y también
candidato donald trump si esto tiene
algún tipo de fundamento legal y puede
prosperar dentro de las autoridades
estadounidenses cómo está santiago un
gusto saludarte bueno la verdad que esto
no nos toma por sorpresa porque lo
escuchamos en su momento al actual
presidente de donald trump renegando
bastante de la democracia de los
procesos democráticos no yo creo que
esto vamos a ver en qué deriva pero
pensándolo en términos de números es
bastante interesante cómo ha
evolucionado la elección en estados en
estos dos días pero pensamos en términos
incluso de voto popular joe biden superó
el récord de votos de lo que fue incluso
el número por el que ganó barack obama
en las últimas elecciones a las
elecciones anteriores cuando el asume
como presidente y candidato demócrata se
termina convirtiendo este miércoles en
el candidato más votado en la historia
de eeuu no y yo insisto el número el
número de personas que votaron ha sido
impactante eso muestra también la gran
conciencia que creo se ha generado en
los eeuu respecto de la política
respecto incluso de esta gran
polarización y división que vivimos tan
tan fuertemente arraigada antonella
muchas gracias debo avanzar con otros
temas de la agenda muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
además de esta elección presidencial
también está en disputa el congreso
estadounidense de ella 35 corresponden a
la renovación del senado y 435 sillas
son de la cámara de representantes en la
cámara baja es decir la cámara de
representantes hasta el momento 203
sillas son para el partido demócrata que
en la legislatura anterior ostentaba la
mayoría y 188 sillas son hasta el
momento para los republicanos
en cuanto al senado en la legislatura
anterior tenía la mayoría allí los
republicanos en este momento la cámara
alta registra 47 para los demócratas y
48 para los republicanos aún hay en
juego
65 sillas para ser asignadas
y el estado de florida es considerado
como uno de los estados pendulares y fue
uno de los territorios más disputados
por los dos candidatos a la presidencia
vamos a ver cómo está la situación allí
y qué balance se puede hacer después de
haber dado a conocer los resultados en
la noche de ayer anthony welsch y en la
ciudad de miami muy buenas noches
anthony hagamos balance allí los
demócratas apostaron el todo por el todo
al voto en la florida sobre todo para el
voto de los latinos por el resultado
resultó siendo a favor de los
republicanos que falló allí para los
para los demócratas
en términos de comparación de los
porcentajes de votos y vemos la votación
de la presidencia pasada
y de hecho muy buenas tardes el
presidente donante había prometido una
auténtica marea roja
florida y viendo los resultados de esta
elección podemos probar que si en la
mayoría del estado de florida
a ganar
el voto
sin embargo hay que hacer autocrítica
dicen desde el partido demócrata para
ver qué es lo que ha pasado en el para
poder llegar a perder hasta 13 puntos
porcentuales desde el voto
respecto a hace cuatro años
según algunas encuestas realizadas a pie
de una
ayer mismo durante el día de las
elecciones
el hecho de que no existiera
muchísimo en el tema que yo bailé estaba
respaldado por la izquierda más radical
de que él era un socialista e incluso
eeuu se podría convertir en un país
comunista también dicen que no
explicado
de bien el tema por ejemplo llenar de
forma
sanitaria que él quiere impulsar
aquí en el sur del áfrica hay una calma
tensa esperando los resultados
electorales gracias a anthony por este
reporte desde la ciudad de miami en el
sur de la florida dándonos un balance de
la votación allí en torno al triunfo de
los republicanos antes de despedirnos
entonces hagamos un recuento de cómo va
la votación hasta el momento de los
votos electorales en este momento van
para joe biden 264 del partido demócrata
tiene que llegar a 270 para declararse
el triunfador de estas elecciones y
donald trump lleva 214 votos electorales
asignados con estas imágenes los dejamos
aquí en este informativo de france 24
siga con nosotros
[Música]